no but they um you know he signed up m
to be the
celebrity guest referee
in a boxing match between the bagel guy
and some other viral video star i swear
to god
get this right so bam they go uh
bam didn't have his meltdown the dr phil
meltdown
yet so the guys that were doing the
celebrity boxing match like you want to
be the celebrity guest referee and bam
was like yeah sure i'll do it and he
took like 2 500 bucks from him and then
announced i gotta go on dr phil i got a
good rehab
he said they're all such pieces of [ __ ]
everyone in this story is a piece of
[ __ ]
i love saying that because i know you
want to beat me
all right so he's sitting uh can you say
indian style anymore
he's sitting crisscross applesauce he's
sitting elizabeth warren's style he's
sitting prairie end
on the floor and filthy wagon burner
filthy wagon burners is also acceptable
yes
he's sitting on the floor indian style
and uh i guess he
doesn't he was trying to leave rehab is
that what's going on
he's hammered there right he's [ __ ] up
he was at the hotel bar and he got
asked to leave the hotel bar as far as i
know they don't
they don't trespass you with cops
especially if you're staying at that
hotel
right they'll go like can you just leave
the bar go to your room they don't
don't want to call the cops on a paying
customer you know what i mean but it's
like
he wouldn't leave and he did that yeah
and it gets weird
so he's here right he tells the cops
he's
he's about to tell the cops that he's
been hired by somebody
hired by a woman to catch some dude
cheating at the bar
i swear to god he's so [ __ ] up so wait
wait he thinks he's like
like some sort of undercover guy now
he's a pi he doesn't think he is
i think he still thinks he's this cool
bullshitter and guys not you're just a
[ __ ] mess now
you're a grown adult at this point it's
time to start acting like one
who's not telling him that cop really oh
that's embarrassing
this is embarrassing i think she agrees
with you roy she's having a
talking to with him
this is embarrassing not for me for you
i love this lady i'm having a great time
i feel great
i don't know about your work trust me i
have my entire division coming
it doesn't work what you're trying to
say and please
i'm not trying to say oh no why don't
you just go to your room at that point
man
go to your room that just sounds like go
to your room but seriously just go to
your [ __ ] room
he's an idiot i'm not trying to say
anything
well it doesn't work i want my phone
so he wants his phone so he's bargaining
with them
to get his phone so he could leave
if you don't get it i keep doing this
look
i don't you don't want to make a big
scene here and i know you
don't want to go that route so let's
just kindly get up and let's go over to
my blog
she i gotta she's trying to work with
him by the way
just get up and we'll leave
to tell somebody
this piece of [ __ ] cheats on his wife
who's that guy standing there you see a
guy there's some guy that's like hey
check it out pam or jared is on the
floor making an [ __ ] himself
like what are the odds that i to go to
this conference and i booked this stupid
hotel
you know i bitched when the company said
that they wouldn't uh bonus me back
unless they stayed at this hotel now
here i am
i'm not even gonna i'm not even gonna
file an expense report
neither do i well then let's get up and
we can go or we're gonna put you in
handcuffs and walk you over there
i hope you rocked me the [ __ ] up hey ben
come on
seriously come on i'm serious this is a
[ __ ] reality tv show
yeah stop sorry
[Music]
gonna die on a bender
[Music]
i'm
bam i think that's the problem by the
way this was
after the dr phil stuff yeah the dr phil
thing was when he was
i i saw it on your show when he was uh
saying that he needs dr phil
yes and then he left the rehab that they
put him in and the next
time we heard from him was this well he
was in this hotel
doing this right after he left rehab
well obviously now you're out right now
but
dude maybe she'll stay maybe she's gonna
fat her head
by the way i don't know how fat this
guy's head was that he's talking to but
bam
you have a pretty fat head too you know
what i mean
oh yeah so this i'm arresting him
oh
did he get arrested or i mean i mean he
didn't get arrested but update
bam was just released from jail bama's
my okay so he was released from just
just but he was probably in the drunk
tank right
yeah yeah yeah this was um
this was uh yeah he was let go but yeah
this was the error this was before
all that okay so this we've never
watched let's play a little bit of an
rtd because it's for those people who
don't know
uh i know you've been covering it a lot
on night wave but uh so this isn't
begging for dr phil how long ago was
this like a week ago maybe
yeah a week or two maybe at most worse
than it's ever been
ever i've disowned my mom i'll tell you
why
nikki i can't stand at no i can't stand
her i'll tell you why
by the way i'm uh this is i'm just live
on paris
it wasn't like a private correspondence
to maybe a possible psychiatric help
like
you know where you can be honest and go
look i hate my mother i want to kill my
wife i can't stand these people so this
is then they can go
it's just on twitter this is just
instagram just
dude my [ __ ] wife's piece of [ __ ] my
mom should be they're all pieces of [ __ ]
a 18 month year old son a year old i
have an 18 month song and why is he
wearing the glasses they give you after
you have like eye surgery
because they're cool oh okay
and uh he's the best i love him to death
and nikki knows that
and if we separate i know she's gonna
use him as bait that's his wife
nikki okay and i ain't playing that
[ __ ] game so you can have him
isn't that lovely and not to mention
isn't that lovely you're gonna stubborn
just like have to have the kid i don't
care as a matter of fact i've
printed five pages about stubborn and
she's too stubborn to read stubborn
that's what it is did she must have
invented it
it would [ __ ] bonkers
so when people sure there's not a scene
from the new joker movie where he's
turning into the joker i know seriously
this is what
seal feels like pennsylvania joker
hey batman i'm gonna take you down and
[ __ ] be with a huge
[Laughter]
the pennsylvania joker is on the loose
and he is angry
you're not supposed to be his height man
jim say bam might be going
crazy [ __ ] a maybe you gotta give me
a billion dollars i'm gonna [ __ ] blow
up the ben franklin bridge
and he's just like all these stupid
references i'm gonna [ __ ] crack the
liberty bell a second time dude for your
freaking
if you don't reveal the identity of
batman
what a terrible joker
and by the way for those who don't know
his his his archnemesis pennsylvania
batman's just like some dude with a bat
that's all it is let's get to the right
let's get to my mom which is the worst
part
batman has 24 hours to reveal himself or
we'll [ __ ] blow up the hershey park
blow up all hershey pennsylvania you
won't even have chocolate anymore dude
i'm gonna blow up a factory that makes
peanut shoes
if you don't reveal batman to me oh
[ __ ] i'm gonna repair the liberty
repair it yeah if you don't give me
batman i'm gonna fix the [ __ ] liberty
bell and
it won't really have any distinguishing
features from other pills
from other bells there will just be a
[ __ ] bell dude
this is hey this is jackass and this is
repairing the liberty velvets
it's what it looks like jackasses them
going around
fixing things hey what's up i'm bram
margaret this is jackass
and this is called fixing the leaning
tower of pizza
yeah it's just a regular tower no it
doesn't stand out at all nobody visits
it
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] christ that was funny
it says negative and she always cuts
people off
you spend more jared i can fix anything
except my life
hey this is stevo and uh this is called
replacing the buddha statues in
afghanistan dude
oh man we're gonna restore culture it's
gnarly
oh oh hey what's up this is bam margera
and this is called time traveling stop
this is the jackass become like this is
time traveling
this is johnny knoxville and we're
putting the nose back on the screen
chris pontius has a [ __ ] belt sander
yeah we're just the show's pretty boring
actually we're just fixing things
oh i love politically correct jackass
it's the best you're just fixing wrongs
oh [ __ ] uh this is preston lacy and this
is called building the wall on the
southern border of the united states
we're not waiting jackass is built more
than trump it's
jackass isn't a joke anymore no it's not
so the real dangerous place in this
seriously
[ __ ] all of a sudden preston lacy i'm
giving up comedy
and uh i'm really passionate about
immigration
hey this is steve i wasn't actually
hacked
hey this is stevo this is called
pretending your twitter account got
hacked
and
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] somebody says bam just
needs to die the [ __ ] he does no are you
kidding me
he must live forever fortnite for night
wave must have
prep waves those are some of the
funniest night wave segments i got him
thank you to vinnie balloons oh sorry
finish
she's already ready to say what she's
gonna say before you're done
that means she's not listening ever
and you get no she invented the time
machine because we go nowhere so [ __ ]
fast just kidding about the time machine
it drives me crazy and we can do this
yeah it's great
but what is it called oh what is it it
does have a name too
and i forgot the name of it but it's uh
somebody in the chat will know from
nightway but it's it's
i don't know he was contacting the
doctor phil people i'm sure they really
don't regret giving him phone numbers
because now he's contacting
all the time and posting on instagram
screenshots of his tweets to them
he wants them to get him in touch with
neil degrasse tyson
i'm sorry no no no i before you even
move on
how can neil degrasse tyson and also the
greek guy from
alien ancient aliens you know aliens
that guy
why because he figured out a way to
explain
black holes by creating a new language
ban margera yes
this guy it's not a manic episode royce
so he needs neil degrasse tyson he needs
the history
boy thank you era remembered strigoi
it's called
okay it's the language and uh
he thinks he can decode black holes
using his own language
that's a combination of the universal
language and
alaskan i don't know and alaskans not a
language it's not
a type of fish it's a yeah it's a type
of type of a state
it's a state yeah um but i i yeah
that that's all i've gathered so far if
you actually go to his instagram you can
see what if he's right
if you go to institute bam margera's
instagram and see the videos of him
screaming and explaining it and
manically like he's losing his mind